du cinéma pour terminer claude sautet
nous avait habitué à des films très
vivants avec beaucoup d'acteurs connus
son coeur en hiver qui sort demain dans
les salles et plus intimiste
il rassemble à l'écran emmanuelle béart
et daniel auteuil et entre les deux dans
le scénario andré dussollier c'est une
histoire d'amour tout en finesse qui se
passe dans le milieu de la musique
michel vial a adoré oui c'est lui qui
donne un qui si j'embarque la cites
appel parce qu'ils ont embêté ne pas
être là pour le dernier jour des camille
alors ce serait bien si tu passais au
studio aujourd'hui oui on prend pas
le coeur en hiver c'est celui de
stéphane incarné par daniel auteuil
un artisan luthier ouvriers de génie mes
personnages hermétique aux sentiments
fermé à l'amour et à la vie
le luthier rencontre un jour une
violoniste et se retrouve soudain pris
au piège de sa façon d'être parce qu'il
ne sait pas au fonds maîtres de l'art
dans sa vie j'ai l'impression à 1 est
assez constant chez les créateurs c'est
à dire que ils mettent plus leur vie
dans leur dans leur art que dans leurs
réactions de la vie quotidienne ils ont
plus de difficultés dans le quotidien et
c'est pour ça aussi qui choisissent la
possibilité d'exprimer à travers un art
ou à travers un métier d'artisan
je ne pouvais plus vivre comme ça vous
devez accepter que quelque chose se
détendre
vous êtes tel raz vous allez venir une
grande musicienne vous avez poussé dont
vous entendrez à l'anti que celui-ci
partait mais vous ne comprenez pas
camion
je parlais de sentiment que je ne
ressens pas n'existe pas ce n'est pas
tout
vous vous en êtes pas c'est une gageure
un peu de faire un film sur un
personnage comme ça qui ne qui ne montre
pas son émotion qui est mystérieux dont
on sait pas bon c'est pas ce qu'il pense
ce qu'il ce qui fait frémir tout le
charme de ce film servi par un
remarquable trio de comédiens un film
attachant parce que tout en demi teinte
c'est précisément dans ces demi teinte
et dans ce silence que claude sautet
nous laisse deviner les fêlures de ses
personnages
enfin